wir schalten nach österreich zu birgit
schmid die das corona virus hat sie ist
eine der erkrankten eine der ja noch
vergleichsweise wenigen erkrankten in
österreich frau cherie danke dass sie
mit uns sprechen viele wollen im moment
nicht dass man sie erkennt wenn sie das
corona virus haben weil sie glauben dass
sie ausgegrenzt stigmatisiert werden
sie halten das anders danke schon allein
dafür seit wann wissen sie dass sie das
corona virus haben beziehungsweise wann
haben sie erfahren dass die korona krank
sind
guten abend in österreich und ja wir
wissen das seit dem fünften mehr über
die daten habe ich jetzt nicht so am 22
haben wir den kontakt und wann das war
der brite
märz sich so nadja betrieb im märz
wissen wird das wir investiert sind also
sie sagen immer wir es hat mich nur sie
getroffen sondern auch hier nehme man
ihrer familie meinen man sowas dann sie
erfahren
der test ist positiv sie haben das
corona virus lassen wir uns ganz kurz
teilhaben an ihren gefühlen in dem
moment erste woran ich gedacht waren
meine kinder meine kinder auch in
kontakt waren und es war das erste
gefühl und natürlich auch eine
unsicherheit wenn man bis heute noch
nicht war es wieder corona virus
natürlich im körper bietet ansonsten von
symptomen herrn mein mann hat bis heute
keine symptome und ich hab die
grippesymptome gefolgt mit
muskelschmerzen ja also sie hatten sie
hatten angst in dem moment klar
nachvollziehbar
die angst war und was mit den kindern
dann erstmal aussortiert zu den
großeltern oder was wohnen sie weiterhin
zusammen wie sind sie mit den kindern
umgegangen
die zwei kernen wie sie in der network
familie die zwei kleinen sind dann mein
ex-mann und die große ist oben in den
getrennten räumen wo wir extra
badezimmer und sie haben und halten sich
dort auch und wie ist man mit ihnen
umgegangen nachbarschaft freunde und so
weiter wird das bedürfnis nicht ganz so
groß gewesen sein in diesen tagen sie zu
treffen
nicht nur mir die ich bin ja dann
am außenrand gerückt dass die
begeisterung war nicht sehr groß also
wie muss noch mitunter nicht so negative
erfahrungen machen da um das wurde auch
hier schon genannt die stigmatisierung
und die history viel zu groß ist auch in
österreich ja und das ist auch der grund
warum wir uns dazu entschieden haben bzw
wir wollten nur einen kleinen bericht
aber dann hat das mediale lauffeuer
angefangen und für uns eine gute
möglichkeit hier dagegen zu arbeiten
die bi hat ein bisschen mit doping zu
tun gehabt weil sie die war die kommune
jetzt bringt meinte mann bzw anonyme
nachrichten die nicht sehr nett waren
und auch hier wurden kurzerhand
beschuldigt wir haben jetzt das corona
gebracht und leute in quarantäne
geschickt ja wobei ich glaube dass bei
uns war es ein lottosechser ja und vier
werden in österreich und ganz genauso
oder umso mehr in deutschland leben ohne
es zu wissen dass wir uns zu haben
die dunkelziffer ist sehr hoch danke
dass sie sich zeigen mit uns sprechen
und vielleicht auch mut machen all denen
auf die das ja noch zukommt
entscheidende frage aber frau schlereth
wie geht es ihnen heute sehr gut gab es
noch jetzt zum abschluss noch vor dem
vor dem letzten schießen noch einen
ratschlag den wir alle sind ja es gibt
ja mediziner hier an der charité in
berlin die sagen 70 prozent der
deutschen werden das virus bekommen das
heißt einmal abgezählt vermutlich wird
uns alle treffen ein ratschlag an uns
alle die den uns das noch bevorsteht den
kopf bewahren und die hörten die
nachrichten und einen schritt nach dem
anderen
herzlichen dank kluger ratschlag aus
österreich ihnen einen schönen abend und
ihrer familie alles gute frische
vorschlägt herzlichen dank